i'm feeling great this is fun this is my
first time on this large scale of a set
there's like
5 000 people the set is beautiful i get
to see all these talented people just
like make food
i get to eat it i think that's my
favorite part they're pulling out sugar
work this beautiful sugar work chocolate
work pastry these are people that have
won baking pastry competitions these are
people that are executive chef pastry
chef hotels michelin star restaurant so
i'm excited to give somebody twenty
thousand dollars
hanging out with like martha and stoop
like they're cool people like we're just
we're just kicking in back there i've
been you know fans of them for a while i
think i've always seen their stuff and
i just think it's just it's cool because
yes they're you know they they built
their success in many ways but then
today that they're just people and all
here to just have fun
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well we're not in the tasty test kitchen
anymore
[Music]